124 يوما من العدوان الصهيوني النازي على
شعبنا الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه في حرب الاباده الجماعيه والتطهير
العرقي التي يشنها والتي لم يشهد العالم
مثيلا لها في وحشيتها وسادتها
وبشاعتها لقد كشفت هذه الحرب عز المجتمع
الدولي في وقفها وفي منع الاحتلال من
الاستمرار فيها وفضحت ازدواجيه المعايير
لدى الدول التي لطالما نادت نفاقا
بالعداله والحريه وحقوق
الانسان في نفس الوقت تقف هذه الدول الى
جانب الاحتلال تشاركه في حرب الاباده التي
يشنها ضد شعبنا وتدعمه بالمال والسلاح
وتغطيه بالموقف
السياسي لا يمكن لاي عبارات مهما كانت
جزالتها الادبيه او اي تقارير اعلاميه او
تحقيقات امميه ان تصف حجم الكارثه
الانسانيه وهول الماساه الحقيقيه التي
خلفها الاحتلال ضد اكثر من مليوني فلسطيني
من ابناء شعبنا في قطاع غزه اغلبهم من
النساء والاطفال والمرضى
والمسنين يموتون
بالقصف يوميا
وبالجوده
وحرائر شبابه وشيوخه اطفاله
وعجائز وهو يسطر بصموده وثباته وصبره المت
عالي على الجراح والالام وتضحياته الجسام
يسطر اروع ملحمه اسطوريه في تاريخ شعبنا
بل في تاريخ امتنا النضال لا يمكن لاي
عباره من عبارات الفخر والاعتزاز ان تؤدي
حق الرجال الرجال الابطال الاشداء اولي
الباس الشديد في كتائب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في كتائب القسام المضفره و را
القدس المجاهده وفي كل ابطال المقاومه وهم
يدافعون عن ارضهم المباركه وقدس
واقصاه الرحمه للشهداء الابرار والشفاء
العاجل للجرحى والمرضى والحريه للاسرى
والمعتقلين الاحرار في سجون العدو
الصهيوني ساتحدث في اربعه محاور الوضع
الانساني والمسار
الدولي ورد حركه حماه على مقترح الاطار
المقدم من لقاء باريس وعن استمرار اكاذيب
الاحتلال ودعايته السوداء واخيرا عن
التصعيد في المنطقه والمواقف
الدوليه في الوضع الانساني وفي المسار
الميداني كما اسلفت لليوم الرابع والعشرين
بعد المئه على هذا العدوان النازي يتفاقم
الوضع الانساني
الكارثي المتام اصلا منذ بدا ال دوان وذلك
بسبب استمرار القصف العشوائي وتدمير
البنيه التحتيه والمجازر الجماعيه وحالات
القتل والاعدام الميداني لعشرات بل مئات
من ابناء شعبنا علاوه على منع وصول
المساعدات الاغاثه الى كافه مناطق قطاع
غزه لا سما في الشمال على الرغم من صدور
قرار من محكمه العدل الدوليه بذلك
ولا تزال الحاجه الماسه والعاجله للغذاء
والماء والدواء لكل سكان القطاع الذين
يفتقدون لابسط المواد الغذائيه والدوائيه
ووحش الجوع والعطش والمرض يفتك بهم يوميا
دون ان تتحرك الدول ولا المؤسسات الامميه
المعنيه التي تتحمل مسؤولياتها الانسانيه
والاخلاقيه في منع موت اهلنا في القطاع
جوعا وبردا وعطشا
ومرضا ان مواصله الاحتلال النازي ارتكاب
جرائم ومجازر مروعه بحق المدنيين
والنازحين من ابناء شعبنا في عموم قطاع
غزه واخرها
قصفه المتعمد لقافله اغاث تتبع الامم
المتحده على شارع الرشيد وقصفه سياره
للشرطه في رفح ارتقى خلالها سته من افراد
الشرطه شهداء كانت مهمتهم تامين دخول
الشاحنات
شاحنات المساعدات الى غزه واجباره المرضى
والمدنيين على اخرا اخلاء مراكز الايواء
في الهلال الاحمر في خانيونس والقصف على
رفح التي ادعى انها منطقه امنه ان كل ذلك
يؤكد مجددا نوايا هذا الاحتلال النازي
باستمرار ممارسته القتلى الممنهجه ضد
ابناء شعبنا والذي يعد جريمه متكامله
الاركان تكشف وحشيته وسديته في انتهاك
صارخ لكل الاعراف والقيم والقوانين
الدوليه اننا هنا نحذر من خطوره اقدام
الاحتلال الصهيوني على ارتكاب مجزره دمويه
جديده في مشفى الامل ومجمع ناصر الطبي
ونحمل الاداره الامريكيه مسؤوليه وتداعيات
ذلك بسبب دعمها لهذا الاحتلال النازي
بالسلاح والمال من اجل استمرار عدوانه
الهمجيه بحق المدنيين من ابناء شعبنا كما
حصل في مجمع الشفاء الطبي في
غزه لقد تابعنا باستنكار واستهجان
بالغين مواقف الدول المتحيزه لاجندا
الاحتلال العدوانيه ضد ابناء شعبنا في فرض
عقوبات على الاونر ووقف التمويل لها بحجج
واهيه وتهم غير مثبته بينما لم نسمع منهم
ادانه واضحه لجرائم وانتهاكات الاحتلال في
قصف وتدمير مراكز الوكاله او مراكز الامم
المتحده فضلا عن اعتقال وقتل العشرات من
العاملين في هذه المنظمه ان الاحتلال
الصهيونيه والاداره الامريكيه الشريكه
والداعمه له في في هذا العدوان يتحملون
المسؤوليه الكامله عن هذه الجرائم
والمجازر وحرب الاباده
الجماعيه ويتحملون مسؤوليه استمرار نزيف
الدم الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه وسيبقى هذا
العدوان وصمه عار تلاحقهم ولن يكونوا
بمعزل عن المحاسبه القانونيه
والمحاكمه مهما طال الزمن او تقادم وهنا
نذكر دول العربيه والاسلاميه بقرارات
القمه العربيه والاسلاميه في الرياض
وبمسؤولية وشرف ومقدسات امته نجدد دعوتنا
هنا لهم جميعا بالتحرك الجاد ورفض كل
الضغوط الامريكيه وتحدي الاحتلال الصهيوني
والعمل بشكل فوري لكسر الحصار على قطاع
غزه وادخال المساعدات الاغاثه والطبيه
لكامل القطاع دعما لصمود شعبنا ونضاله
المشروع ان موقف قاده الكيان الصهيوني بعد
124 يوما مضت على الحرب الاجراميه على
المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه في قطاع
غزه وفشلهم في تحقيق اي من اهدافهم
العدوانيه المعلن عنها تؤكد بما لا يدع
مجالا للشك ان نتنياهو وحكومته يسعى بشى
الطرق الى مواصله تضليل الراي العام
الصهيوني واطاله امد العدوان رغم ما يتلقى
جيشه المهزوم من خسائر في الارواح
والمعدات وهو يحاول الهروب من استحقاقات
مرحله ما بعد العدوان وارجاء مواجهته
للجان التحقيق حول الفشل المدوي يوم
السابع من اكتوبر تشرين اول وما تلاها من
انكسارات لجيش الاحتلال المهزوم على ارض
غزه والذي لا يزال يتلقى الضربات الموجعه
على يد المقاومه الباسله
ثانيا في رد الحركه على مقترح الاطار
المقدم من لقاء
باريس لقد قامت الحركه بتسليم ردها حول
اتفاق الاطار للاخوه في قطر ومصر وذلك بعد
انجاز التشاور القيادي في الحركه ومع
فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه شركاء المقاومه
والميدان وقد قدمت الحركه ملاحظاتها بما
يضمن وقف اطلاق النار الشامل والتام
وانهاء العدوان الهمجي على المدنيين العزل
من اطفال ونساء وشيوخ وادخال المساعدات
والمواد الاغاثه وتامين الايواء للنازحين
وضمان الاعمار ورفع الحصار عن قطاع غزه
وانجاز عمليه تبادل
الاسرى لقد تعاملت الحركه مع المقترح بروح
ايجابيه وذلك رغم ردود الفعل الصهيونيه
التي حاولت القفز عن ابسط حقوق شعبنا في
هذا الاطار فمنذ اليوم الاول للاعلان عن
هذه الورقه ورقه الاطار تواترت التصريحات
الصهيونيه التي تؤكد استمرار العدوان على
قطاع غزه كما جاء على لسان الارهابي
نتنياهو الذي تحدث عن رفضه سحب جيشه في
غزه او الافراج عن الاسرى في سجون
الاحتلال وقد كرر هذا الموقف قبل قليل في
مؤتمره الصحفي قبل لحظات في هذا السياق
سارع وزراء حكومه نتنياهو من المتطرفين
الى تاكيد مواقفهم الفاشيه
ودعواتهم المجدده الى العمل على تهجير
شعبنا الفلسطيني من قطاع غزه في مسعا
لتعطيل اي مسار يفضي الى وقف العدوان على
قطاع غز
وهنا ندعو الاداره الامريكيه التي لازالت
تقدم كل سبل الدعم العسكري والسياسي لكيان
الاحتلال الارهابي ولا زالت توفر الغطاء
لحرب الاباده التي يشنها على شعبنا
الفلسطيني في غزه ندعوها الى الكف عن هذه
السياسه الاجراميه والتي تقود المنطقه الى
الاشتعال وان تعي ان وقف العدوان على قطاع
غزه ورفع الظلم عن شعبنا الفلسطيني
والاعتراف بحقوقه كامله غير منقوصه
وتمكينه من تقرير مصيره وبناء دولته
المستقله كامله السياده وعاصمتها القدس هو
عنوان الاستقرار الوحيد في
المنطقه اننا نثمن دور الاشقاء في مصر
وقطر والدول كافه التي سعت وتسعى الى وقف
العدوان الغاشم على
شعبنا في اطار متابعه ما قدمناه من افكار
وفي اطار حرصنا على تحقيق افضل النتائج
بما يخدم مصالح شعبنا ويوقف معاناته ويخفف
الامه من خلال وقف العدوان عليه ومن خلال
تحقيق اغاثه كامله ورفع للحصار واطلاق
للاعمار فان وفدا من قياده الحركه برئاسه
الاخ المجاهد الدكتور خليل الحيه عضو
المكتب السياسي للحركه سيتجه الى القاهره
لمتابعه هذا الامر في اطار رعايه قطريه
مصريه وعليه فاننا ندعو شعبنا الى عدم
الاستجابه لكل اشكال الكذب والتضليل التي
يمارسها الاحتلال والى عدم التاثر بما قد
ينشره من دعايات تهدف للتاثير على
معنوياته ونؤكد ان المصدر الوحيد للمعلومه
سيظل المقاومه التي صدقت شعبها على مدى
اكثر من 120 يوما من المواجهه مع الاحتلال
كما ندعو مجاهدينا من كل فصائل المقاومه
في كتائب القسام وسرايا القدس وكل الاجنحه
العسكريه المجاهده الى الاستمرار في
المواجهه والتزام الحيطه والحذر من غدر
هذا الاحتلال والحذر بشكل خاص من غدره في
ربع الساعه الاخيره في هذه المواجهه لا
سما ونحن نسعى لانهاء هذا العدوان بالصوره
التي تليق بتضحيات شعبنا
ومقاومته نحيي صمود شعبنا الاسطوري
ومقاومته الباسله خاصه في قطاع غزه ونؤكد
اننا ومع كاف القوى والفصائل الوطنيه
ماضون في الدفاع عن شعبنا على طريق انهاء
الاحتلال وانجاز حقوقنا الوطنيه المشروعه
في ارضنا ومقدساتنا واؤكد اقامه دولتنا
الفلسطينيه المستقله كامله السياده
وعاصمتها
القدس ثالثا في استمرار اكاذيب الاحتلال
ودعايته
السوداء لازال الناطق اسم جيش الاحتلال
يواصل نشر اكاذيبه ودعايات السوداء
الكاذبه ضد شعبنا ومقاومتها وكان اخرها
ادعاء عثوره على وثائقه ومبالغ ماليه
لحركه حماس مستلمه من ايران ورغم ان كل ما
اورده هو مسرحيه مفبركه ودعايه سوداء
ساذجه تثير السخريه وتكشف حجم الحمق
الغباء فهو يعلن عن اكتشافه لخيط رفيع حول
العلاقه بين المقاومه وبين ايران وكانه
يكتشف العجله فالجميع يعرف ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لها علاقات واضحه مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران قائمه على اساس دعم
الجمهوريه للمقاومه في فلسطين ودعمها
لصمود شعبنا الفلسطيني
وهو دعم مقدر ومشكور وعلاقه قائمه على
اساس الاحترام
المتبادل مع كل فشل يلاحق هذا العدو يحاول
يائسا ضخ المزيد من دعايته الكاذبه
وادعاءاته المغرضه في تشويه نضال شعبنا
وصموده وفي تشويه التفافه حول
مقاومته التي
ثبت امام العالم جميعا ان يكذب بحقها ما
اثار سخريه جمهوره حتى من حماقته
وسذاجته ان هذه الاكاذيب
والادعاءات وعلى الرغم من محاولات
الاحتلال المحمومه لتسويقها وترويجها امام
المسؤولين والدبلوماسيين عبر العالم الا
انها لم تنطل لاحد فقد ضحد الواقع وفندت
تحقيقات الصحافه العالميه المستقله بل
وحتى
تحقيقات صحافه العدو نفسه في هذا السياق
نجدد التاكيد على ان هذه الدعايه
الصهيونيه التي تتساوق معها بعض الوسائل
الاعلاميه الغربيه دون ما تدقيق او تمحيص
لن تفلح في تشويه عداله قضيتنا ومشروعيه
مقاومه ونضال شعبنا وندعو كل دول العالم
والحكومات
ووسائل الاعلام العالميه الى عدم الانجرار
وراء هذه الدعايه السوداء التي ثبت كذبها
وزيفها وبعدها عن الواقع كيف لا ومن
يطلقها كيان لم يقم الا على الكذب والزيف
والتدليس
ونشدد على ضروره التحلي بالموضوعيه
والمصداقيه وعدم التعاطي مع هذه
الدعايه رابعا في التصعيد في المنطقه
والمواقف
الدوليه ان تواصل القصف والاستهداف
العسكري لدول الامريكي لدولنا العربيه
الشقيقه في اليمن ولبنان والعراق وسوريا
الذي ترتكبه الاداره الامريكيه والاحتلال
الصهيوني يعد اعتداء سافرا على سياده هذه
الدول الشقيقه وتهديدا مباشرا للامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه ويثبت من جديد ان
الاداره الامريكيه بدعمها للعدوان
الصهيوني هي المسؤوله المباشره عن اشعال
مزيد من الصراعات في المنطقه مما يحملها
مسؤوليات تداعيات هذه الصراعات ونتائجها
الخطيره
واتساعها نجدد هنا تثمينا لموقف جمهوريه
مصر العربيه الشقيقه في رفض كل مخططات
الاحتلال ومشاريعه العدوانيه حول محور
فيلادلفيا ونحذر من خطوره اجندات العدو
النازي في ارتكاب المزيد من المجازر بحق
اهلنا النازحين بغرض التهجير القصري كما
ندين بشده كل خطوات التطبيع مع الاحتلال
الصهيوني المجرم القاتل للاطفال والنساء
ونستنكر هنا اعلان رئيس الارجنتين عزمه
نقل سفاره بلاده لدى الكيان الصهيوني الى
القدس المحتله ونعتبر ذلك تعديا على حقوق
شعبنا في ارضه ومخ لفه لقواعد القانون
الدولي باعتبار القدس ارضا فلسطينيه محتله
وندعو كل الدول والاحرار في العالم الى
فضح وعزل هذا الاحتلال وممارسه كل الضغوط
لوقف عدوانه وجرائمه ضد شعبنا وحقوقه في
ارضه ومقدساته ونحذر كذلك من التساوق مع
مخططات الاحتلال في استهداف وكاله الانر
ونعد ذلك مؤامره تهدف الى تصفيه حق عوده
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وعقوبه جماعيه ضد
شعبنا
وتشديدات
تاكيد ان عنوان الهدوء والاستقرار في
المنطقه هو وقف العدوان الصهيوني على
شعبنا بشكل مباشر وفوري وانهاء
الاحتلال الفاشي عن ارضنا
ومقدساتنا ومحاسبه قاده الكيان الصهيوني
على جرائمهم بحق شعبنا الفلسطيني وتمكين
شعبنا من انجاز حقوقه الوطنيه واقامه
دولته المستقله وعاصمتها القدس
الرحمه والمجد والخلود لقوافل الشهداء من
ابناء شعبنا
ومقاومتنا ومجاهدي امتنا على طريق تحرير
القدس والحريه لاسرانا في سجون الاحتلال
والنصر لشعبنا ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر
او استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته استاذ اسامه ياسين تلفزيون العهد
العراقي قلت تحديدا ان هناك وفد سيذهب الى
القاهره لمناقشه المقترح متى سيذهب الى
القاهره بدايه وتصريحات نتنياهو هذه
الاخيره هي تشي ان هناك يعني صعوبه في
الوصول الى حل وتعنت اكبر لاسرائيل ما
الذي يحدث بشان ذهاب الوفد وتصريحات
نتنياهو بالنسبه للوفد يعني كما اشرت نحن
قدمنا تصورا استلمه الاشقاء في قطر ومصر
وهناك اتفاق على ان يتواجد وفد في القاهره
سيغادر الى القاهره غدا هذا الوفد سيتابع
اي الحوار حول الاجراءات بهذا الخصوص وما
قدم في ورقه الحركه وربما ما سياتي من
ردود على هذه الورقه اما بالنسبه لتصريحات
نتنياهو فنحن نعتقد انه يحاول هنا ان
يتعالى على ازمته هو يعاني من ازمه داخل
حكومته ويعاني من ازمه في اداء جيشه
ويعاني من ازمه في في شارعه ويحاول ان
يعبر خلاف ذلك على اي الاحوال اصراره على
مواصله العدوان يؤكد بشكل قاطع ان الهدف
من العدوان على غزه هو عمليه اباده جماعيه
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني نحن سنبذل كل جهد
لحمايه شعبنا
سواء بالمقاومه في الميدان او بالحراك
والجهد السياسي لوقف العدوان تفضل ما صحه
الوثيقه التي نشرت في الاعلام على انها
مقدمه من من
[موسيقى]
الحمات الحقيقه الحركه سلمت
اي ردها على ورقه باريس للاشقاء في قطر
ومصر وذلك كما اسلفت في حديثي قبل قليل
بعد التشاور الداخلي والتشاور ايضا مع
فصائل المقاومه وموقفنا في هذه الورقه
ارتكز الى ضروره انجاز حقوقنا من وقف
للعدوان وانهاء للحصار والاغاثه وايضا
تبادل الاسرى مع
الاسف تم تسريب نسخه قبل النسخه النهائيه
الى الاعلام انا استطيع ان اقول انه يمكن
اعتبار ما تم تداوله في الاعلام حول الرد
هو قريب جدا الى الصحه والى حد كبير ونحن
سنواصل
متابعه الافكار التي قدمناها من اجل
تحقيقها ان شاء الله تعالى تفضل ما
تعليقهم على بيان الخارجيه السعوديه حول
العلاقه مع اسرائيل مقابل اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه
ا اولا التعبير عن موقف داعم لحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني هذا
اي يعني خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح وهي خطوه
مطلوبه ويجب ان تكون سلوكا عاما اما
الحديث عن اي عمليه تطبيع مع الاحتلال او
مقايضه حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني بالتطبيع مع
الاحتلال او الاعتراف باي حق له في ارضنا
فهو امر مرفوض نحن نتمنى ان يكون الموقف
العربي كاملا هو الانحياز للشعب الفلسطيني
رفض التطبيع مع الكيان الصهيوني قطع
العلاقات مع هذا الكيان الارهابي بل وفرض
حصار عليه حتى يتنازل او يسلم بحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني بالنسبه للورقه اللي عم يتم
التداول فيها هي اتفاق على مراحل ف السؤال
بيتعلق بالمرحله الاخيره او الما قبل
الاخيره بحيث بتكون حركه
حماس افرجت عن جميع الرهائن
الاحياء شو ضمانكم انه اذا افرجت عن الهاء
الاحياء رح
تقدروا تفاوضوا وتجيبوا وقف اطلاق نار
دائم بعد ما بعد ما تفرجوا
عنيا اولا انا لست بصدد مناقشه تفاصيل ما
ورد في ورقه لانه هذه ورقه ستخضع لنقاش و
ستطور وربما نحقق افضل مما كتبناه فيها اي
لكن بكل الاحوال نحن نهدف ان نصل في نهايه
الامر الى وقف شامل وكامل لاطلاق النار
هذا واضح حتى في الورقه المسربه وواضح
ايضا في الورقه التي قدمناها للاشقاء في
قطر ومصر يجب ان لا يظن احد ان هناك تنازل
عن وقف هذا العدوان خاصه وقد راى العالم
ان هذا العدوان هو عباره عن عمليه اباده
جماعيه وهو في سياق مخطط لطرد الفلسطينيين
من ارضهم واذكر هنا قبل اسابيع قليله تكلم
وزير ماليه الكيان الصهيوني عن موقف واضح
في هذا الامر عندما قال ان الحل للوجود
العربي في قطاع غزه لم يقل الوجود
الفلسطيني لانه لازال لا يعترف
بالفلسطينيين كشعب الحل هو ابعادهم الى
كندا او الى دول اخرى هذا هو الهدف
الحقيقي من المشروع الصهيوني ولذلك يجب ان
لا يتوقع احد اننا سنقبل صيغه تعطي العدو
فرصه لتحقيق هذا
الهدف هل من هي الدول الضامنه غير قطر
ومصر هذا الاتفاق اي نحن تحدثنا عن دول
ضامنه قطر ومصر تركيا وروسيا وايضا الامم
المتحده
[موسيقى]
سؤال فيما يتعلق بالمقترح
المقدم ما هو موقف موقف داخل الحماس حول
هذه حول الشروط بعض التقارير تقول انه هل
يمكن تؤكد لنا موقفكم حولها هذا
الامر فيما يتعلق بالمواقف المختلفه لحماس
لابد من القول ان هذه دعايه سياسيه
اسرائيليه وتعكس الوضع الموجود داخل حكومه
اسرائيل الذي تسوده خلافات والانقسامات
ويردون عكس ذلك على حماس الموقف داخل
الحماس متوحد الصفوف وليس هناك اي شك حول
ما ينبغي نفعله وما ينبغي ان ان نبعثه
للوسطاء وما قدمناه لهم يعكس موقف قياده
القياده التي يحترمها الجميع ويقبلونها
وان اي التزامات من قبل القياده
ستكون هي كل ما يعكس موقف
حماس شكرا
لكم